in five four three two one
what's up you smelly smelly people so
dug in yes brain you stinky bastards oh
yeah
take a shower take a shower that we just
did a jiu jitsu
the other day and I am [ __ ] wrecked
I'm wrecked actually uh hurt my groin
how I don't know if I if I did it from
jujitsu it alone I think it's just from
when people put their feet on your hips
sometimes it slips down hitting area
yeah dude I couldn't walk this far kick
your balls I don't like it I think
everybody beat me up yesterday you beat
the [ __ ] out of me dude you [ __ ]
Wiggly Japanese man even I haven't
really grappled like that in 18 years
you know what's crazy about that jay-z
it's like you don't you don't realize
how much you don't know what to do when
somebody grabs you until somebody grabs
you oh yeah oh yeah oh [ __ ] I don't know
what to do yeah thank you you know just
when we were younger like if if somebody
took you to the ground you start
swinging as much as possible yeah but
when somebody knows how to like really
control you on the floor I'm like I
don't I don't know what to do I don't
want to get to the floor because I don't
wanna get dirty and I don't like I don't
like grappling on concrete oh yeah yes
sucks yeah you know what's hard I'm
grappling on the beach oh yeah it did
that for my birthday when I was like 19
or 18 we're doing grappling on the beach
we just had a big birthday thing on the
beach just a powwow yeah and everyone
started grappling on the beach and in it
was fun but like first of all like I
don't know I guess it was it was a bunch
of guys in like really tiny shorts
grabbing on the beach and then there was
sand just being thrown everywhere yeah
yeah it gets in your eyes it gets in
like it's it's pretty rough it's like
beach sex dude
yeah and it's skin-on-skin when you get
sand in between that [ __ ] that shit's
not not good man but that's all like the
Brazilian used to do it on the sad
mm-hmm that's [ __ ] crazy yeah that's
how they developed their moves and [ __ ]
dude we had I remember in high school
did your friends just box out of nowhere
just put on gloves just boxes yeah -
they look stupid though cuz they didn't
know how to bark we just swung in yeah
so one of my friends her her older
brother and then I had this friend in
high school named Gabriel this dude got
buddy an this [ __ ] boxes dude and at
this place called northern water park
and it was so [ __ ] funny because he
got bum-rushed so they just started
swinging at each other
it's what bum-rush up so fast this full
flipped over this like this concrete
slab like this oh [ __ ] what's so funny -
its we were younger we used to think
that we knew how to fight yeah and so
that we just put on gloves start
swinging yeah yeah but remember
everybody would just start just putting
on clothes and throwing yeah its they do
this thing they swing like that actually
I actually knocked out one of my friends
like that yeah and it was you're not
supposed to go 100 percent but kids do
yeah they don't even know what not going
100 percent is yeah and then we don't
think about like brain damage we know
about getting rocked no and so this guy
I mean mind you this dude is he's like
was smaller than me he's like smaller
than you oh really size difference wise
right but picture you but then like a
hundred and like 20 pounds and all
that's like me in high school yeah and
I'm like 200 pounds right yeah if we
don't know how to fight yeah if you land
a hit though I'm going down exactly so
this dude you know he's just started
swinging on me super hard of money yo
there's like some friendly [ __ ] I think
all right I [ __ ] just swung like a
blind swing and I cracked him on the
face his [ __ ] head looked like it
turned around to the back and he just
like knocked out on the floor have you
made him a [ __ ] turbine engine I
thought you know it sounds a lot cooler
than it is by pretty sure if you record
it it's just me closing my eyes and
maybe caught a lucky one it's a
worldstar fight video yeah I watch that
[ __ ] there's a there's a Twitter handle
that has just all hood fight yeah dude
it's [ __ ] crazy man I like how they
they're but their head is all the way
back like they're fighting stance it's
like all the way back and then they
finger like chin is up yeah did you see
that one where the dude these two dudes
fighting like in the middle of the
street they're just like what black dude
just chillin on the corner the guys for
some reason somehow switched one black
yes
yeah this was like in New York yeah
cause it was like a white guy yeah
hidden he was chasing after the black
guy and they were fighting yeah and then
the that one black guy he ran behind the
other black guy and then when the like I
thought the black guy was him then he
punched that guy what the [ __ ] dude it's
like literally thinking that all black
people look alike and he just swung at
anybody he didn't even know he was
fighting to different people ah it was
so [ __ ] funny dude I know that was
pretty funny there wasn't last time you
got took this fight [ __ ] so a long time
huh yeah I I do know that Bart was there
Bart got into the fight yeah I mean that
fight together it was in Little Tokyo
but I had to be twenty-two so what's
that like 12 years ago yeah like I mean
we've a real street fight right yeah
yeah not not like a like cuz we spar all
the time yeah but yeah like a street
fight yeah it was 12 years ago yeah I
mean I had a lot of close calls but it
was always self-defense
like who was is one crackhead that was
like yelling at everybody at the park
remember that one oh yeah you were
yelling at my dog and then like trying
to fight and then he started almost
attacking that lady with the with the
baby cart and then that's when I had her
like kind of run in and and and try to
distract his attention that [ __ ] was
like holy [ __ ] this guy might attack me
but I'm always afraid to fight
crackheads or people that are high cuz
um they have superhuman strength I just
don't care they don't you could smack
them a million times they might not feel
it I'm here too crazy yeah I'm scared of
crazy you could kick him in the balls
and they might not do anything like a
Buddhist monk you know okay they hold
the two bricks yeah [ __ ] kicks to the
balls no like I think yeah the last it
was so memorable because it was like a
revenge thing right the guys bashed up
my car because oh [ __ ] yeah man um one
of these guides
he's his girlfriend at the time I did
her favor something happened I forgot
what it was I think I helped her out
through a problem and
as a nice gesture she made cookies for
me the next day and he saw that and he
got [ __ ] jealous right so he went on
aim one night and then he was like hey
like I'm stranded
he had the password to her account so he
was like hey I'm stranded I need help
oh he set you up yeah so I was like okay
where are you at and I'm like [ __ ] well
I guess I could take my mom's car and
help pick you up and then drop you off
right and then I was like well I was
friends with their older brother tools
like where's your older brother at why
can't he do it yeah she's like oh well
he's not in town right now in it but
this is like this party's weird like I
don't know how I got myself in here and
I was like you know what's so funny in
that situation as he's typing this out
and you're writing to this this girl
right different ways for you not to do
it you wouldn't think that he would
think oh maybe he's not trying to [ __ ]
my girl does this guy yes I was like
alright [ __ ] it you know okay I'll come
pick you up
and then so like I pulled up to the
driveway
and then I turned off my car like an
idiot
there's no music there's no sound so I'm
like I didn't get out of the car yeah
and then so I think I think I texted her
or something at the time but while I was
waiting in the car
a bunch of dudes with masks rolled up
they bashed my windows oh and all this
[ __ ] I was trying to turn the car on and
then like I don't know like I guess the
car wouldn't turn on because maybe I was
what a [ __ ] nightmare yeah cuz I was
panicked so I wasn't so I just kept
going did you do it like right and I
wanted to run these guys over or
something I just wanted to drive off and
when they broke through the windows they
stuck their hands in with pepper spray
and they maced me
oh yeah and in and in so they just kept
cracking the car and then they all like
scattered like ants so nobody pulled me
out of the car damaged me they just
pretty much like assaulted my car yeah
and then so I was like covered in pepper
spray I didn't know at the time but I
was going home and I just I just [ __ ]
ran all the red lights and and like Oh
before that I try to chase them down and
they
hop some fences and I try to get to
where their car was because I was just
gonna crash my car into there to stop em
and [ __ ] yeah yeah but then they just
bounced off so I drove away and then
basically I got home my mom was like
what the [ __ ] happened and my mom had a
drive to the to the what do you call it
the like our auto manufacturer we called
mechanic mechanic yeah yeah
which by the way is a legendary drifter
oh yeah he's a legend [ __ ] it he's a and
his son is my friend too Ken gooshie oh
yeah yeah dude a were shocked they were
like what happened and I'm like man some
gangsters just bashed my car you know
yeah and anyways so so yeah my mom had
to go through that and that's when I
recognized I thought I had glass in my
eyes and I was at home and I was like
trying to wash out the pepper spray but
it's crazy like during the dren 'el in
the pepper spray doesn't really [ __ ]
with you oh like it just makes you cry a
lot and you're blinking a lot but I feel
like pepper spray might not be the
strongest thing to do like when you want
to get away from people yeah but anyways
so that that happened and then I started
investigating who it was I had a hunch
it was her ex but who were the other
guys you know and in so her ex were or I
guess what she told me was they were
going through a rough time they weren't
there they weren't actually a couple
anymore or something but he still had
her password and she totally forgot
about that
oh yeah so he um
he was military so I guess he
conveniently planned this so he goes off
to his like base or whatever you know so
he left for that and then um so I was
like well if I can't get him I'm gonna
get all of his friends oh and I started
figuring out one by one who they were
and like there's been some times when I
fought
a lot of them up one of the guys
actually that I found out I stalked him
at a barber shop and I started getting
haircuts from him just to [ __ ] with his
head yeah and then I would have him I
would ask for him specifically to cut my
hair
oh Shannon I would have him cut my hair
and I'd have conversations with him as
if I didn't know anything yeah and then
um one day he said hey Joe I was like
well I just want you to know that I'm
sorry for what happened but I wasn't
there that night oh [ __ ] so he was I
think he felt weird about it yeah and I
was like okay I was like um do you know
who was you knows yeah I don't hang out
with those guys anymore but he told me
the names I was like okay cool cuz he
was really close to those guys yeah so I
was really close to just like basically
[ __ ] with them for a little bit and
then one day like maybe during his lunch
and it was another time when um one of
his other buddies were boldly laughing
at me
so me and my buddy oh [ __ ] that makes
you mad yeah we were we were so we were
so we were at a corner at a stoplight
by by in and out and then he pulled up
next to me this this [ __ ] is like a
spoiled rich kid he had a BMW in high
school and you know he was always looked
like a wannabe gangster right so I drove
up and then he pulled up next to me and
he started laughing and smiling and I
was like oh [ __ ] no [ __ ] way he
wasn't a part of him yeah little did he
know next to me was one of my most
hot-headed violent friends and as soon
as I looked at him and he started
laughing at me and I said that's him my
friend immediately opened the door and
then his door and he started kicking him
in there and that guy's girlfriend was
like stops oh hey so I put my car in the
ebrake I [ __ ] did one of those Tony
Jaa slide slide over the [ __ ] hood
things well it probably looked like a
more roll
and then we started beating his ass like
in the middle of the street because he
probably didn't expect us to chorus
that's what he's laughing yeah
and then um that was one that was one
incident right so one by one we were
starting to knock out these guys and
then the the thing was I never got the
ex he just disappeared at the face of
the this earth yeah um and in one day so
me and my bar were me barred and a
couple of our buddies like they know
this story a lot of people knew what
happened to me yeah right
and then cuz I was like struck with
revenge like I was like this was this
happened right around high school 17 18
so I probably held this anger up until
my early 20s yeah and by that time like
me and Bart we were all a part of a
Fight Club like we went we that's when
we first met like we did MMA yeah and
then I'm funny story those guys they
love fighting
but they're also very honorable people
and they never joined a gang or anything
like that there's military guys but
they're very violent guys right so those
guys as in Bart and his friends so they
created this crew called the
peacekeepers that sounds like some [ __ ]
Bart would do is they're so stupid so
they a side story they would go to frat
parties and then like they would be the
unofficial security and if any fight
broke out they would [ __ ] up both a gut
both of the guys that were fighting they
just a lot of they wanted an excuse to
fight but not feel guilty about it
they were so stupid yeah they they were
like oh we're fighting for justice so
like they fight like guys they'll fight
though don't run into fight they'll go
to house parties with gangs and then
like they'll start fights with them but
they're like we're not a gang though
we're trying to set the record straight
like you guys are [ __ ] stupid dude I
used to think you guys are so cool man
I'm like yeah that's a different way to
look at it I mean you're 18 19 yeah I
can dumb right that's what good - yeah
yeah we're not
we're just looking for other people to
fight so you [ __ ] everybody better
fighting for justice you know to me up
so I'm so stupid I don't know like we're
not a gang or a [ __ ] security group
you know stupid you know what I mean
that's one of the reasons why pirate got
so buff is there was they got into a
fight at a club there I guess it was
their peacekeeper crew or whatever but
it was big [ __ ] like huge right and
um you know a couple of scrawny ass
Asian guys like they were landing hits
nothing was affecting this dude nothing
and then like you know I think that
really like bruised his ego or like
bruises like confidence and and he was
like [ __ ] dude like I really got to get
strong cuz like he's like I could land
these hits but if the other guy stronger
there's no way yeah yeah and then so he
started working out but yeah like so I
already had this group right like I
wasn't a part of this group I just like
at that age like I didn't have my gang
with me I left that life I started going
to college actually you know some of the
guys in Bart's group were were very
helpful in that yeah like like they were
never they you know they they got out of
boot camp they're military guys they
were like kind of showing me that there
is a better way to like live like
amongst the world you know yeah so I was
like oh these guys are dope like they're
you know they're down for their [ __ ] but
they don't have to be a part of anything
and then they want to elevate themselves
go to college and [ __ ] like that so I
really like the guys and and so but they
were down for me like they would fight
for me all that stuff so they were like
and if anytime we see these guys man we
got your back or whatever and in all the
other previous rivalries that I had like
if I had beef because it was
gang-related I didn't care anymore
because to me it was like sure like you
know they might have shot so-and-so or
whatever like but I thought that that
was like not a legitimate reason and I
never had hate yeah I never cared to me
it was like okay it was a gang rivalry
and it started over stupid [ __ ]
the times it's it started because
somebody in my group was a dumb hothead
and he just wanted to start stuff yeah
and we got caught up in it but I I never
cared so I was like whatever if I see a
guy that was supposed to be a rival or
whatever like I'll just be like [ __ ] it
if they want to but I'm not gonna start
anything and I don't have any hate
toward that yeah these guys I took it
personal it was personals [ __ ] right yes
I mean I don't know I just couldn't let
it go and then so we were at this bar
and then um one of the buddies was like
hey he's in the bathroom oh [ __ ] it was
what he want to do and then I looked at
him like I was like [ __ ] dude let me let
me have some time with him just me and
him in the bathroom like you guys go to
the door like hold it hold it down for
me yeah right so I go in this guy's
washing his hands the guy that laughed
at me mm-hmm at on the street right he's
actually like like a little bit taller
and and just I don't know but I knew I
could [ __ ] his ass up yeah so I went in
and then um um I think Bart was at the
door and another buddy of mine went into
the stall or something like that no no
actually it was just me and then okay so
it was me first and then Bart and
another guy at the door and then when I
went in there I didn't know that that
guy's buddy was taking a piss like in
the in the in a toilet side yeah so he
was washing his hands and I came in and
also like remember me [ __ ]
and then he looked up and then as soon
as he looked up he kind of like threw
his hands up so when he did is like
little gangster throwing hands up like
that I [ __ ] 300 kicked him in the
stomach
oh [ __ ] and then and then we just
thought it like going at it right like
just throwing fists and then I feel this
foam from the back of my head
so I guess one of his buddies oh [ __ ] I
mean they he was in the bathroom too
yeah so I went down and then as I was
getting up both of them were on me
kicking me punching me so like I was it
somehow turned around where I was by the
like papers paper or towel dispensers
yeah and then like I'm covering up and
then like there's all this
commotion and that's when Barton and my
other buddy opened the door they come
around they pull the guys off of me and
they started launching right yeah and
here's the thing the guy that was really
bold and acting tough when the table's
turned around he started screaming for
help oh my god after he jumped with you
guys yeah dude so he was like hell right
and then um my other buddy was outside
coming in and and he was like oh you
need help and then he says yeah there's
guys and he just started whaling in his
[ __ ] face oh [ __ ] he's like oh you
need help and then he grabbed him by the
back in his holy piece yes and then um
so yeah yeah and the funny thing is my
other friend was kind of buzzing during
the time and yeah I mean a [ __ ] face
thinking that I was one of them oh my
god instead of a [ __ ] so what right
when he kicked me the guy's got away
yeah and then everybody got away and it
happened so fast and then I got up in my
um I knew I [ __ ] got him in the face
pretty hard because my my ring finger on
my right hand was like [ __ ] it was
dislocated yeah that's the first time I
need someone so hard that it dislocated
right yeah I was like all [ __ ] got him I
must have got him good right yeah but
it'd knock nobody out so I was like [ __ ]
so then at this point we're like oh [ __ ]
let's go catch him in the parking lot so
we all ran and then this is when like
the security guard Hey like all this
commotion was happening and in it was
like a movie where we just went through
the kitchen and then it's like we ran
through the kitchen and while I'm
running I'm like up here like putting it
back into place cuz I was like this my
finger was like this and I'm like oh
[ __ ] and I put it back into place and I
ran out and then all of us got into the
parking lot when we got there these guys
loved bashing cars man [ __ ] cowards
they had all their weapons out they had
all their weapons out and they're
walking toward they knew which one of
our cars were and they were walking
toward that are you guys gonna [ __ ]
bash our cars like a little [ __ ] we're
all right here let's go and then they
had weapons yeah they didn't want to
attack us
with their little weapons and in these
Samoan security guards came out and in
there just watching the whole thing and
they're like hey we're gonna call the
cops right yeah so I was like all right
how about this me and this guy just go
one-on-one and then it doesn't involve
anybody yeah yeah and then the guy just
kept talking and yelling and being a big
guy and I was like let's do it man
that's like a stop talking that's so
[ __ ] annoying you know those guys
like when when when there's a security
guard they start taking if they're sure
get louder and louder yeah and then
their friends were playing the game with
them like pulling them back like let's
go let's go let's go hey nobody's
holding you back you could come right
now and then he's like can I talk to you
man can I talk to you and I was like can
I talk to you yeah and I was like what's
what kind of trick is his [ __ ] kind of
poo am I gonna walk up to him and he's
gonna sucker punch me yeah so I went up
to him and I was like what's up and he's
like I wasn't there that night and I'm
like yeah right
like why the [ __ ] did you laugh at me
yeah he's like yeah I don't laugh at you
and I'm like yeah you laughed at me on
the street when I beat your ass on the
street that's all like I wasn't laughing
I was no I was all the same with so I
was smiling you were saying was ugly
that's gonna make me even more mad he
was lying yeah and in and I was like so
who did it then I was like you weren't
there and he was no I wasn't there that
day I wasn't I was like were any of
these guys there and then he's like umm
yeah but nah like out but I was I'm done
though like you already got me two times
he's like isn't that fair even Stevens
he wanted to make it he wanted yet his
pride right but he wanted it like he
still wanted to like negotiate and I
told his ass like until your friend
shows up and makes this even I'm gonna
keep gating you and your friends
non-stop yeah
cuz I don't know I was just like
bloodthirsty yes like every single one
now I know all you guys I was like all
you guys every single [ __ ] here
I'm gonna get every single one of you I
don't give a [ __ ] because you're his
friend I'm gonna [ __ ] you up if I see
you on the streets I don't care like
haha I was kind of like I was stupid
back then you know yeah like I just I
was like any way to hurt him any way to
make them feel like
Rett or anything yeah I never got a
chance to sit down with the with that
guy
yeah or have a fight with him or
anything he just ran away the domain
guide the ex-boyfriend I suppose yeah
man yeah and um yeah I mean that that's
that was my last fight and then I mean I
grew out of that like I I don't care
like I don't
I forgive them like to me it's like
we're kids we do stupid things it's
crazy because it's like it goes back to
that topic that we were talking about
earlier podcast where it's not even
really you could tell you could like
unaffiliated whatever you're doing but
it's literally the people that keep you
around that gets you into this [ __ ]
yeah like that one girl yeah who's still
in her [ __ ] drags you into her
problems and you don't you didn't expect
that [ __ ] you're just gonna help her out
yeah man and I heard that um like he
would beat her and he was such a she was
just a psychopath like he he's one of
those guys that are like so attached to
their girlfriend that you know that
they're just an abusive jealous like
they think everybody's trying to have
sex with their girlfriend and [ __ ] like
that you know do some of those guys I
just want to talk to me like dude
your girl's [ __ ] ugly I mean she was
she was pretty she was a close friend of
mine yeah I would have dated her too but
um you know you what pissed me off the
most was it was like it was like yeah
there could have been something there
between us but what really happened was
it was a good friendship
yeah and in also they weren't together
yeah cuz they just broke up so it was
fine yeah I didn't know that but I also
didn't know what an abusive [ __ ] he was
you had no idea he was such a piece of
[ __ ]
like and what a jealous [ __ ] cuz it's
like usually when I find out a guy is
extremely jealous and this is I think
this is very I'm in high school you know
I mean it it's not like it doesn't
happen to adults but I think it's more
common in high school that they get
violent and they always want to fight
people like to me like when I find that
out like I'm just like now I don't want
you okay people don't even grow out of
that [ __ ] dude
I was that when I was in case it's kind
of funny but I was in Cape Town I was a
I used to go eat at this Deni there's
like one Denny's in Cape Town that
everybody goes to and I used to live in
these apartments that were like walking
distance from there I used to eat super
late at night but every time I would go
to Denny's I used to get the same [ __ ]
actually get this thing called the
Midnight's lamb burger which is like
beef patty hash brown eggs bacon and
this is [ __ ] bomb ass burger but I
just go there starving just because you
know it's late at night you go out
drinking you want to go eat something
but I was so [ __ ] hungry I remember I
was hungry and tired and those is a
couple sitting across from us and they
got that sampler platter with the
chicken tenders and everything else i
sat there just staring at it and it's do
stared at my [ __ ] grown man what's up
I was like Bryce they're dead you know
Stanley just [ __ ] chicken tenders oh
yeah it's really just looking at me this
dude I mean automat just for me looking
over he please I'm looking at his girl
what was his response huh what was his
response no that's what he said he was
like he's like you stared at my home I
usually comedians are so good with that
[ __ ] yeah that it catches people off
guard you don't even know what the his
response started laughing diffused it
yeah you started cracking up looking at
her chicken tenders man it looks Bob
this was like okay he's cracking up but
you know her she was just like yeah
beresan mean I wasn't even looking at
her I was looking at those the [ __ ]
sapling planet respect my girl I know my
[ __ ] look at first like she was even
cute see I'm the opposite dude I like it
when guys like look at my girls cuz
that's - you wanna [ __ ] her [ __ ]
horny bastard the people get mad man
like there's like dudes I remember in in
high school like specifically I know
this guy he used to get this we just get
mad at people dogging him but it wasn't
even the fact that people are dogging
him it's him staring at them
uncomfortably so they're looking back at
what the [ __ ] he's looking at and he
thinks he's like all these people are
staring at me over there man he's
[ __ ] dogging me I'm like he's not
dogging you he's trying to figure out
why the [ __ ] you're staring at him dude
like you're you're dogging him dude stop
staring at people dude you [ __ ] angry
[ __ ] do you used to be afraid like back
in a day when
group of guys stared at you in your life
off they're gonna come [ __ ] start
[ __ ] with me yo when I when we first
started YouTube when I first started
YouTube like I didn't realize how big
the platform was yeah and you know like
Sacramento certain parts aren't aren't
really nice yeah so I was selling up my
car like really late at night and these
dudes you know you can tell when they're
thugs or some [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] Lee they
got the profile right so they're coming
up and I'm popping my car and I just see
this car these these this car full of
dudes look at me and they kind of look
talk to each other go around and get on
my oh [ __ ] I'm not to get jacked that's
the first thing I thought I'm like you
think you're gonna jump out of the car
and they're gonna Jack my ass you know
I'm like [ __ ] yeah oh [ __ ] like I'm not
in the mood for this [ __ ] so I'm getting
nervous I'm a little scared you looks
like a car full of dudes what the [ __ ]
am I gonna do I have no weapons on me
you know I'm like okay [ __ ] what I'm
gonna do just [ __ ] get this gas with
pop the gas on flames agenda Michael hey
do you that do from you to yo man you
[ __ ] farty bro Oh Jack man my palms
are sweating and [ __ ] I mean like this
that's what people used to do back in
the day I'm like okay these pools are
gonna take my [ __ ] they're gonna [ __ ] me
up from you you two really changed the
way I started seeing people yeah cuz I
think we both well I mean even if you're
not gang-related I think if you hung out
with lower income Asians yeah that late
90 or even 90s to like early 2000s right
everyone experienced some form of gang
banger II yeah like either you got you
fired yep or some gangsters were bored
so they wanted to Punk you yeah or
harass you or you you might just be on a
date with a girl and they just want to
beat you up yeah just for fun you know
so just roll up on people for no [ __ ]
reason yeah or they're just drugged out
and they think you're from a rival gang
and like you know the way we all dressed
kind of fit the profile yeah it was just
the same fashion that was cool to wear
was also the kind of clothes that could
get you in trouble yeah but it's like
I'm not gonna dress like a straight geek
yeah I'm not gonna wear it you know like
I'm not gonna wear clothes that my mom
wants me to wear it
yeah so like it was it was it was
difficult because like the style in the
fashion
then would would attract that bad
attention yeah like people drive up oh
these guys are bangers for sure they're
bangers and then they'll want to start
[ __ ] with you even if you're not you
know so cuz a lot of my friends that
weren't involved in gangs like they
would get hit up yeah they would get
punked and so so like I don't think
people understand that and what kind of
PTSD that would create cuz you're
constantly paranoid yeah ii guess your
life if you're gonna go eat late at
night well we were uh when we first
started youtube - i remember well my
senses are down now but whenever
somebody I would feel eyes on me I'm
like she seems gonna [ __ ] me up so we're
gonna come over here and start bullying
me like like they're gonna cause you
know like they a lot of guys would do
this we're like they just want to fight
for no reason so they'll make something
up they'll come up to you be like hey
man how come you said this to my friend
yeah you're like I didn't say anything
yeah but then if some of them they're
like these predators right where they
know that if you're easy prey and it can
boost their ego and they can bully you
then they'll just don't they'll really
like go hard do a lot yeah are you
[ __ ] disrespect me and then if you
back down then then they're like all I
know I could [ __ ] this guy up because
he's such a easy so a lot of problems
that used to get into especially when I
talk about a lot of the fights I got in
high school was specifically because
like number one I always hung out with
so you know I think I hopped a lot of
groups a lot right so there was
definitely that the set of friends that
I had I still have to this day there
were really really good people and those
are the people that I connected with the
most and eventually I started morphing
into who they were yeah cuz you know I
connected with them I'm a good I'm not a
bad dude yeah and but there's also
people that you grew up with that you
just you there's still your friends yeah
even if they make poor choices and you
still hang out with them so that would
always get me in [ __ ] trouble but the
problem that was that I didn't really
look the part of the guy that would hang
out with these type of people all right
yeah but and I wanted to I mean this
world we're childhood friends am I just
gonna [ __ ] leave them yeah we grew up
together that's it you know but because
of that you know what the class is and
the dweeby class I was like a dweeb II
dude I'm also a big guy yeah so I felt
like people would try to target me out
of that group when I hung out with them
because I look like the nicest yeah I'm
the dweeby kid with the glasses
yeah and
also a big guy so if they could beat up
a big guy yeah then it makes them look
there you go boost they say yeah a boost
for them but what they don't know is
that number one because I look like this
I had to defend myself
constantly growing up all the [ __ ]
time that's like a lot of my short
friends yeah little friends you have to
they're like some of the best fighters
they had so many people picking on them
yeah so when I tell these stories like
used to get in fights eh it wasn't
really it's like I'm defending myself
like I'm not starting [ __ ] but people
would always start [ __ ] with me and I
had a such a [ __ ] short temper yeah
you know the kr8 [ __ ] so I'm like
alright let's [ __ ] go and I just
start swinging like a [ __ ] and
awesome we don't expect it they don't
expect it because they expect to beat up
the big guy in the group that was a good
weep so they can like chanting or soft
yeah like oh the big guy I'm gonna knock
his ass out like I remember in high
school there was this time so there's
this girl named uh so I I was friends
but there's his elementary school and
she's like this sweet little Mormon girl
and so I was kind of late to get lockers
and she didn't have a locker partner so
we became Locker partners and we're
still friends to this day so this is
after school we we in order for us to
get a locker you have to wait after
school and go to the office and the
lines [ __ ] huge is like during the
summer time before school starting so
it's hot as [ __ ] and I remember I went
to go put in this this paper with her to
get my locker and I waited in the line
for like two hours and this [ __ ] dude
comes up and he goes you hold up real
quick and he like pushes me aside and he
like knocks my paper out of my hand and
he puts his [ __ ] in I know I cuz he just
cut him like he tripod oh yeah and then
you know Sarah Sarah remembers me from
elementary school and even in elementary
school I had a really bad temper she's
like oh [ __ ] yeah and so I look at him I
might hold on a second and I grab his
[ __ ] I was like this is [ __ ] and he had
his locker partner with him too
I grabbed his [ __ ] and I [ __ ] toward
that oh [ __ ] dude in his [ __ ] face oh
I'm like what's up what do you do about
it
yeah cuz I'm an easy target I look like
an easy target what I was wearing - I
was running like these baby blue Jordan
shorts a [ __ ] animal on t-shirt you
know whatever whatnot and like a baby
blue cat and this dude comes up did not
expect that
yeah and I just look at him and then
she's like what am I [ __ ]
boom I push him against the [ __ ] wall
I'm like what's up right everybody you
know like in high school when somebody's
about to throw down the perfect circle
forms and you know like in high school
I'm not I'm not a like a thug or
anything else it was
unexpected for people to see that it's
because I've got a good iraq reaction
yeah they're like well right and so I'm
sitting there and and I used to say this
[ __ ] all the time I'm like swing at me
and see what happens and I'm like
literally like an inch away from his
face I'm like just [ __ ] swing at me
and then like I'm literally about the
clock this dude [ __ ] nasarah grabs my
hand yeah and she goes just calm down
and I felt so bad because you know she's
like the sweet little bro and I remember
I just like stared at him and she's like
holding my hand back and I'm like
looking like an inch and there was a guy
dude just shocked he was a shot you just
quiet yeah he just say [ __ ] yeah because
that he could [ __ ] with you he's not a
small guy either he was honestly like
about a couple and just told me to so
it's like if you wanted to throw down
he's gonna throw down yeah and like
looking at dude I might say something I
look at his partners like want you to
something yeah they just like they like
[ __ ] you and they just walked off and I
was like - I would hear that Korean
liquor store owner yeah like why is he
talking like that he looked like a
really studious kid yeah but that's the
thing too is cuz I think I chose to hang
out with good people in high school so
and I and I like that about myself but
because you know I think like how I grew
up where I grew up and the other guys
that I grew up around with they kind of
taught me how to fight and not to be a
little [ __ ] yeah so it transfers over
but what people don't know is that that
violence was like survival for your it's
like self-preservation yeah like like
you can't keep getting picked on yeah
what am I supposed to do yeah your your
egos damaged your sense of self is
damaged you get into depression but you
need it was like it was such a
dog-eat-dog time it was so weird because
like I don't think people and I think
like younger kids don't understand that
so when they hear these stories they're
like oh you're a gangster that's not a
gangster I'm like the average kid this
is the average yet that's true gangsters
were guys that were shooting each other
exactly and stabbing each other and I
mean it still happens today I'm not a
part of that world and I'm not around it
but it was so prevalent that like
everybody was being harassed yeah like
so much it was so [ __ ] up it was such
a weird time when I look back at it now
and it's like okay and it's funny
because anybody that I talked to within
the same age range no matter where you
are in the world I mean in America
it was it was a rough time like it was
just I hear the same stories man and I'm
like damn that's so crazy and I think by
the time I was in college high school
was all like a little bit different it
was like a emo era I mean they were
still fighting yeah like am ia different
that's when my fingers it was trying to
dissipate right yeah cuz we're about
three four years apart yeah in my time
it was already dissipating it was like
being academic was becoming cooler yeah
right so that was I was just at that
weird stage where those remnants were
still there you also what grew up in
Sacramento and I think like this is like
Sacramento Long Beach Fresno yeah you
know they like that that gang culture
like ghetto culture is still strong do
Sacramento State is still strong there
man and like it's kind of sad for me
because I kind of want to see that shift
happen yeah but I feel like sometimes
Sacramento in certain parts just like
digressing like there yeah I mean it
takes a lot because we live in a
different world almost it's like we live
in the same physical world right but
like I didn't know there was this whole
world outside of that yeah yeah and I
wish I was introduced that because when
I wouldn't man when I when I go back to
Sacramento now so I stayed in the south
part of Sacramento South Sacramento like
in Elk Grove was a nice area too because
that's that's like I was kind of close
to that area so I've stayed there but
South Sacramento was really bad and
that's all that I knew I didn't know
about Downtown Midtown like really like
Natomas I'm like I know people who live
there because they went to my church but
I never really went there it wasn't a
spot for me I didn't feel like I belong
there but there are such nice parts of
Sacramento that seem like another
universe because I just it wasn't
something that I knew about yeah you
know in my mind my mind was this small I
was like this is what Sacramento is this
is how everybody is here yeah but
there's actually people who have really
good jobs who have a lot of money who
don't do this type of [ __ ] that I just
never knew about people like men you
know so I was very ignorant for sure
yeah I think it's I like the internet
now because like a kid that isn't of
that world like like let's say if I was
a kid in that time and we did have
online but it wasn't like what it is
today where you could watch the life of
others you can watch people becoming
successful from nothing and like you
just heard stories right yeah but like
there's a way for nonviolent kids and
whatever to have access to someone that
they might be friends with yeah cuz I
really got into hip-hop and I think that
would have been a way for me to climb
out of it earlier yeah and I mean yeah
it's just the environment was such a
[ __ ] place and it didn't matter cuz I
hopped from different high schools like
no matter where you went you know and no
one was I guess safe from that kind of
bullying and it's also buys it was it
was the cool thing to do was glorified
at the time yeah like it was so cuz now
it doesn't happen III heard I feel like
if you're in a gang not say the people
arguing it's just it's very niche and if
you are your ride or die as [ __ ] now you
know but now being that I guess what I
call is a dwee but you know it's it's
not not in a negative way but liking
nerdy things whereas it was considered
back in the day it's the cool thing it's
okay to express yourself and like the
things that you like and you find your
community then yeah which it wasn't like
that before it's like you had to fit
into a certain mold and if you didn't
you're the dweeb or you were a cool
person you had less options yeah we even
had less options for music and I think
if you were Asian back then all you
listened to was like trance yeah R&B
yeah hip-hop that's it and if you listen
to alternative rock you were [ __ ]
weirdo you're trying to be white if you
listen to like oldies or whatever it's
like I don't know maybe you had Mexican
friends who introduced you to it like
that access to music different life
styles all that like there was no
choices man well not much if you grew up
in a like a minority dominant
neighborhood you know like yeah it was
different it was really different
because I know Asian kids that grew up
around like all whites yeah so for them
they felt like they didn't have much
choice but whatever their friends were
listening to yeah yeah I was kind of
cool because I just remember in high
school had a big shift where it was like
my junior ish senior year I'll just like
know how you'll [ __ ] with me and my
things anymore like just do whatever
makes you happy it's like to inquire
don't I wish I did that man yeah like
stuff like that like I remember like
junior and senior were my happy
yes I was like you know what like you
can't be on the fence about everything
you know like you can't be this dweeby
looking kid that wants to hang out with
these thugs yeah and you you you're
almost sometimes ashamed to hang out
with some of these people who are
treating you great yeah cuz you're
afraid of what this group is gonna say
about you say [ __ ] this you just joined
choir and enjoy yourself but it was like
the most enjoy but senior was like the
most enjoyable for me because I
literally did whatever I wanted and it
made me happy yeah and those fed if all
those friends that I had then that
majority then fizzled I maybe only
talked to one or two of them and they
don't do that [ __ ] anymore so I don't
even know how good of friends they are
like I I really don't know and I think I
like the fact that I could be associated
with this people and it I felt like it
made me feel cooler or something like
you had their acceptance I had their
acceptance and it also I also kind of
felt protected too yeah I felt like
these dudes no matter what if something
goes down I can't hit up these guys
they're not gonna defend me yeah some of
them I mean mind you something was a big
part of it for me yeah feeling protected
the other thing like uh somebody yeah
cuz I I think people don't even realize
to a lot of that gang [ __ ] happens from
like fear like you get punk so much
people will group up together [ __ ] you
up yep and then everybody in the group
is revenge thirsty and then like it's
like oh my homie got punked well that
brings back memories of when I was
punked let's go boy the bully you know
did I remember some dudes that would be
in that group that um they were like
arguably if they got into a one-on-one
fight they could get their [ __ ] ass
yeah but because they knew they had all
the homies around them they would be the
loudest [ __ ] course cuz we were like
what most of us are 110 pounds Asian
guys yeah we had like one Samoan guy in
the group or something you know yeah
yeah do that for us a big [ __ ] guy in
the group you know yeah it was such a
weird time man like I look back at it
now and it's just like damn dude there's
so much [ __ ] to think about I think
like kids now even though we had I think
sometimes kids have it worse now because
of Instagram like I hear like kids they
face school popularity on who has the
most Instagram fault really
amen damn they're like oh how many
followers you have that's like how much
that's what they asked like oh you got
this amount of followers and if they
have a lot of followers they try to [ __ ]
with them more because they want to gain
their clout right so that's the new high
school dynamic will make sense cuz they
see all these youtubers
and Instagram models and everybody like
living life living large I didn't even
know like before Instagram I didn't know
like what kind of wealth and things were
out there in the world
yeah like yacht part what the [ __ ] yeah
if you only remember like that Biggie
Smalls [ __ ] like when him and puff was
on the yacht like you know yeah Wow
but how prevalent it is now like it
seems like everybody's doing it but you
yeah but back then I was like oh it's
only the rich and the special rappers
that are doing it people people now they
just because they want to front like
they have everything on Instagram yeah
cuz you know you they see a dude with
the yacht they have a yacht party right
yeah like prior to that to our thoughts
it was like oh there's one individual
that's getting this yacht and he's
inviting all these people out but maybe
people want to imitate that lifestyle so
much I know kids now they I don't know
kids but I know kids do this like
they'll get all their friends don't just
pull all this money together just so
they can get get that yacht party or
something dang so I think it look like
they stunt yeah you know and it's it's
it's just like a Airbnb so they'll rent
out a yacht or whatever an air B&B and
they'll felt like you know I'm balling
I'm rich or whatever but it's like do
you and thirty people render that place
out not to say that's wrong but you're
acting like you didn't do that yeah
what's the whole point of this man
you're broke it's cool I know but I
think the whole point of it is getting
laid
yeah that makes sense yeah yeah yeah
yeah probably would probably work too
right I was 17 I'd do the same [ __ ] yeah
I think I'd be pretty I'd be pretty
[ __ ] up it was four I mean I you know
I don't know maybe if I look back on it
now if I was if I was on Instagram I
feel like I would've been that high
school kid that was super against
Instagram and I just put a got Punk for
it I think I think like we had our own
set of problems which was like survival
and violence and kids you know our
friends getting shot or going to jail
that was our world I mean there was
probably so many other things going on
at the time but for sure it was a much
more crazier thing like I remember like
even outside of the ghetto group like
like the whites were going through their
own set of problems with like drug abuse
and overdose and dying and like it was
I think overall a more hardcore like
life-or-death type of time yeah and I
think now it's more about mental health
and a lot of people committing suicide
or like like it's it's not like
in-your-face survival and violence maybe
in some areas but it seems like the
problems that they're dealing with is
more like you're too damn young to be
seeing the world so damn fast yeah and I
mean that's that's everybody right like
that's what they thought of our
generation and generation before I don't
think they're wrong either oh yeah like
we just have a different set of problems
is what it is
they might not have somebody pointing
guns at them or or yelling at them but
they'll have I think I'd rather have
that they'll have this feeling of you
know like I'm not good enough and in
constant depression this is like there's
just too many things to compare yourself
to now yeah and there's actual metrics
to it now yeah that's the sad part it's
like you know there's there's there's
even like a certain level of cool that's
like it's subjective you know there's no
number to it there's no digital dial
that you can see like oh this is the
cool person rank it up you see that
number that means how important that
they are yeah and I you know he's even
TIFF said like she's not gonna have
Isaac look at they have a phone yet
because of the reason because mentally
he's not ready for it yeah and I a
hundred percent agree I think so too
I a hundred percent [ __ ] agree you
should [ __ ] take him to the Stone Age
yeah maybe my abacus yeah take that I
have a pager I wonder to it like Isaac
like I feel like sometimes like he's
probably already like the popular kid
because yeah he has clout yeah yeah but
he doesn't have you know their stuff to
show it but you know still out there I
mean what you gonna do I mean there's
celebrity kids there's like [ __ ] always
you know oh I thought about - what I was
thinking like you know when when Mary
I'll not have a kid I don't know if I
want to put his face up his or her face
up you're not trying to make money yeah
you know I'm not even [ __ ] like I'm
like that's a very poor business move
David you know but I think I get scared
where I'm I feel like I'm kind of
setting well it's different you know I
think some parents can handle it very
well I don't know if I can handle it
very well as a parent you know where I
think like I see this kid being a
[ __ ] loser because of it like I'm
special you know I don't want my column
there unspecial every time on video
there's no you're cute as [ __ ] that's
all you got going for you just troll
your kid like you ain't [ __ ] just so he
knows I think no matter what you can't
avoid problems they're just gonna have
their own set of problems I get scared
them yeah I'm more scared about how I'm
gonna handle it I gotta I can barely
handle my own problem that's true you
know like I just hope I'm not violent
I hope so too yeah man because the apple
doesn't fall far from the tree right
like I got art we got [ __ ] up yeah and
I know like when I'm set off I got anger
problems and like you know I just hope
that I can control myself
and I break that cycle yeah and I
changed the way I handle [ __ ] cuz like I
probably might not beat them but I might
like verbally abuse them or I might yell
at them
too much like a form of it yeah so it
might be some form of abuse like I don't
want to do that and that's what scares
the [ __ ] out of me man do we talk about
stories sometimes where I think like if
I tell you about the story of I got my
ass be it's funny to us if you tell
somebody who's never seen violence as a
kid they're more if I jus yeah I told
the story to my friend yeah this time
where my dad chucked a [ __ ] office
chair at my head yeah and I'm cracking
up and she's looking at me like you know
what the [ __ ] oh that's not funny to you
they're like you need to see it there
yeah oh that's what do you think we got
a sense of humor this is a coping
mechanism
yes I'm not trying to be an entertainer
yeah this is force this is to keep my
[ __ ] sanity dude therapy you sons of
[ __ ]
yeah y'all look back at em like yeah I
guess that's not really funny you don't
look to me for some reason cracks me up
nah man I think it's hilarious I think I
think emotions are funny irrational
actions are funny yeah but it's like
what are you gonna do you can't change
your the past yeah just got to change
the way you look at it so [ __ ] yeah
well there you go that's about an hour
hour in cool we knocking him out killing
out yo so I hope you guys enjoyed that
that pot yes we actually had a specific
topic but we maybe will do it for the
next I think this one's not it was
really good though yeah yeah I think I
told that full story before I hope that
you ever did yeah [ __ ] peacemakers
party you know why that cracks me up
because that still something Bart would
do till this day I know right that's not
changing justifying his violence it's so
funny and he's righteous about it so
like back then though I was like that is
so [ __ ] cool bar and that is that's
so next level and he's like yeah I know
Jesus Christ that's literally him dude
[ __ ] tight yo so you could check out
genius brain on Spotify podcast iTunes
remember all those other audio platforms
if you're us if you see us on iTunes
give us that five star and remember
every Thursday is gonna be with Joe
Sundays we have another random guest so
Thursday and Joe is is our slot together
Sundays we have a rotating guess and
stuff like that genius brain will be
moving to a different location soon but
we're still popping out these podcasts
make sure you check us out sooner or
later we're going to be dropping merch
and we might even start a patreon later
on you don't even know what's up but
it's gonna be poppin as hell it's gonna
be dope and we'll see you guys next time
til next time goodbye face